Alright, so I just found the example, so you can see we have the Fair Valley gap here.
And price created this high inside the Fair Valley gap.
And we also have this Fair Valley gap.
Price came into this Fair Valley gap, right created this low here.
So what happens then?
Price takes out the high that was formed inside the Fair Valley gap.
And then it goes to the low that was formed inside the Fair Valley gap.
So this is like, I think one of the best ways to find your daily buys or actually you can
use it as a trading model itself, but I wouldn't suggest it.
So over here you can also see that we have another Fair Valley gap, right?
And this high was formed inside this Fair Valley gap.
So price takes out the high.
And then you can see that we have this Fair Valley gap as well, right?
And this low was formed inside the Fair Valley gap right here.
So price takes out the high that was formed inside this Fair Valley gap.
And then it goes towards the low that was formed inside this tiny Fair Valley gap.
So you can use it as I say before to find your daily buys or a model itself.
So I hope by now it is clear and just wanted to make a very short video about this because
this is very easy and it is very, very effective.
Remember it only works with Fair Valley gaps.
And also one thing to note is that let's say price comes into the Fair Valley gap, right?
And as soon as it comes and creates a high and then the high gets purged, then you don't
have to look for anything that Fair Valley gaps becomes invalid.
Only one high is allowed in one Fair Valley gap.
If there are two highs that Fair Valley gap is invalid, okay?
So for example, this is another high that is created inside this Fair Valley gap, right?
And it took out the first high.
Now I will not be looking at this because the job is done here.
So I will move on and look to find another setup.
If there's one high like this, then that liquidity pool is valid.
So yeah, that's what I wanted to tell you.
So let's move on to next chapter.